le show je sais que tu es un petit peu
blessé par ce qu'a dit sébastien balle
et là sur ce plateau qui cédera pas
j'étais beaucoup plus blessé par ces
propos à monsieur que par les propos
d'alexandre ménard c'est bien ce que je
dis j'y vois pas ce que j'ai dit à
sébastien parce que j'en étais pas là la
semaine dernière justement on va écouter
les propos que tu as tenu sur ayem est
derrière avoir annoncé que si tu
regardes le bayer pas non si ça a quand
même été monté en épingle par ayem et
c'est elle qui a fait chuter les
informations et vite
évidemment que alexandre belhadi qui
n'était pas garde du corps du président
mais qui travaille à la présidence de la
république ne va pas devenir garde du
corps de ayem elle a profité de ça pour
faire le buzz non tout ça parce que
parce que il a rencontré son mari ou son
ex mari est peut-être pour des affaires
ou pas ils peuvent se rencontrer
maintenant tout ça a été monté en
épingle et je comprends qu'il ait cette
réaction
vous m'apprenez oui je maintiens
c'était déjà il vient de dire avant
qu'on regarde le magnéto qu'est ce que
j'ai dit il se rappelle même pas de ce
qu'il est les six noms me rappelle de ce
que j'ai dit qu'est ce que j'ai dit de
mal la geria alors je vais vous
expliquer ce que vous avez dit matt
savage la semaine dernière vous avez
commencé par faire des propos
diffamatoires
via oui parce que vous êtes pour vous
avez enfin c'est magali j'ai droit de
dire ce que je pense non mais c'est bien
le téléphone et vous avez dit j'ai eu à
y est mais elle vit que c'est quelqu'un
qui est plus bas que terre et qui vient
d'accrocher des si on peut re a passé le
magnéto donc là je trouve que la limite
c'est diffamateurs c'est pour ça que je
je je suis intervenu dans cette histoire
donc n'importe qui ça peut vous arriver
à vous demain vous avez une descente de
police
il ya des gens qui arrivent chez vous
qui font une perquisition qui mettent
des scellés vous vous retrouver à la rue
vous avez un enfant qui est en bas âge
vous avez votre femme il faut bien aller
quelque part quelqu'un quelqu'un vous
reçoit chez lui c'est très bien
j'appelle pas ça vivre au crochet y est
plus bas que terre donc c'était pour moi
un peu taper sur l'ambulance c'est pour
ça que j'ai réagi par rapport à cette
histoire maintenant
quant aux démentis dont vous avez parlé
de libé je suis désolé moi je n'ai pas
vu maintenant et pas assez travaillé je
remets passant je remets pas en question
il a été recruté
émis des hypothèses l'huile a affirmé
détenir une guérilla lilas et il a été
repris nulle part parce que le plus
simple pour vous avez réagi très vite la
semaine dernière vous savez utiliser les
réseaux sociaux
oui merci au top donc voilà pourquoi ou
pourquoi vous ne l'avez pas fait à ce
moment-là au débat de me dire quand est
ce que veut dire en faisant du monsieur
badin on est très belle et bonne raison
qu'ils parlent de diffamation par
rapport à magali 8 même il a fait de la
diffamation sur le plateau pour la
simple et bonne raison qu'il a affirmé
sur ce plateau détenir la vérité de
cette fameuse histoire en disant que
j'ai monté en épingle tout ça est à fait
normaux et les façades et je vais
demander de vous écouter vous écoute
sans toi il a dit que tu faisais du buzz
autour de cette analyse à demi mot pour
mot remettez le magnéto que j'avais
monté en épingle cette affaire de toutes
pièces oui ou non monsieur tout à fait
idiot oui mais vous l'avez dit donc je
venais moi vous avez été toujours tu
réponds non mais c'est résister pour que
je me lève et je te promets que derrière
tu réponds même avec naturel et comment
tu la montée en épingle je ne suis pas
d'accord parce que quand j'ai été
absente vous êtes fait un plaisir de
tous parler maintenant je suis présente
et je veux parler à montrer comment il a
monté en épingle et j'ai rien attendre
de prendre un cas prête à la parole est
donc toujours ce débat d'idées nous
comment ça a été monté en épingle
moi je dis que de ne pas répondre cette
émission par avec envers les gens sont
absents je te laisserais attendre après
il faut que les gens comprennent vif été
monté en épingle
comment je ne sais même pas mot 6 me
après tu réponds prési prési je sais
très bien ici le fait de ne pas démentir
sur le champ et de laisser dont 6 e rang
serré parce qu'on n'a pas été reprise
je suis désolé alors qu'aucun
journaliste en france ne l'a fait
puisque ça n'a pas été reprise à une
opération se sont pas des journalistes
mais ça n'a pas été repris je suis je
lai j'ai les mains
on me regarde pas bien sûr j'ai pas vu
non rien le match lui envoyer toutes les
informations est-ce qu'il les a sortis
mais laisserait demande à adrien ils
allaient cependant pendant ce temps là
juste une question je devais perdre le
fil de ce que je dois dire mettons donc
défini avec lui c'est que ces gens aient
envie que je dis c'est que de bon de ne
pas répondre à la polémique en disant
que c'est faux c'est l'entretenir et ça
c'est connu si l'on doit entretenir
watch qui est vrai sébastien cg des
textos envoyés où il ya un journaliste
de libé qui dit bonjour je suis en est à
libeller cherche à infirmer ou confirmer
l'info d'abord sur le compte instagram
puis ben un bref pour ayem est donc ayem
qui répond bonjour chers fabien
alexandre bella est un ami de longue
date en aucun cas n était chargé de la
sécurité de celle de mon fils que ce
soit de près ou de loin c'est une rumeur
c'est vrai qu'elle a répondu j'en avais
répondu non safari sympathisants
libéraux faut lever la bouche ou alors
je lève la main alors je vais faire ou
non connaissent en fait dans ce milieu
d'accord ils peuvent se contacter ils
peuvent avoir des informations dans les
coulisses et dans les deux sens mais
bien sûr que non les concurrents ok vous
me voyez concurrents ou pas partage pas
galère donc en fait vous sent en
formation vous permettait d'affirmer une
histoire en disant que j'ai monté cette
histoire dans deux ans en début à la fin
vous avez été remis je termine je veux
alors que vous exprimez c'est à mon tour
mais traiter mythomane de feuilles qui
délire non juste si ceci si vous l'avez
dit on va pas repasser le magnéto vous
l'avez dit moi je vous le dis vous êtes
un grossier personnage je vous dire
clairement et vous êtes insultant
et vous êtes dangereux parce que vous
mettez dans la suite des choses
on va retirer on a tous les matchs à des
amis et pour voir vous ne répondez pas à
la question de savoir quoi vous n'avez
pas arrêté la politique d y répondre
mais d'abord je veux inviter budget gelé
arrêté dès le début mais de toute façon
dans ce milieu des médias que je réponds
nous répondre si j'avais répondu on
aurait dit abel de serre ges bas moi
aussi que tu sais ton sa mère tu mets
des médias quand ça t'arrange suspicieux
avec toute voie du buzz partout toi est
[Applaudissements]
ce que les amis c'est parce que vraiment
faut qu'on avance a mais non mais faut
qu'on avance mais à un moment donné
quand on m'a dit soit je peux m'exprimer
et des pompes et combien vous allez voir
c'est important pas c'est juste une
phrase de vous a rien de précis on en a
fait l'annoncé du jour sur ayem alger là
je suis désolé mais moi je veux dire que
quand même cette personne est dangereuse
parce qu'il tient des propos on a
compris raby et tutrice
j'ai bien compris j'ai bien compris mon
chou l'âge avancé plus en plus je pars
est ta promo en plus et je m'en fous là
de ma promo bon ça m'arrange un peu
parce que c'est un truc de cosmétiques
sa monnaie non je le paye toujours passé
je veux pas que tu as passé parce que je
vais te le dire et qui est
nécessairement dans les loges et ça
c'est vrai je crois que j'ai jamais été
aussi je lis de temps sans fondement
mais on s'en fout mathieu je suis ici
sur un plateau j'ai été accusée insulté
par un mec je connais pas et ça je
trouve ça déplorable et il a juste donné
que parfois on a du beau domaine et de
folles et ils m'accusaient en pensant
gratuit freeroll question mon choix
parce que tant d'autres il ya aussi ayem
à m pourquoi est ce que quand tu viens
ici parce que c'est peut-être une
question mais ça m'intéresse au sérieux
le rapport que j'ai avec 12 25 personnes
séparées parce que vous essayez de
comprendre aussi autour de toi autour de
toi y arriver c'est pas qui tu es mais
on aime ça normal de ces catégories tu
arrives avec cinq derniers accords il
faut cette largeur là
les heurts ont déjà tout c'est une
grande erreur
las pampas qu'animateur tu devrais
rester neutre je lui dis gratuit tu
rates on sert de base est premièrement
que j'aime avec cinq ou vingt cinq
personnes à angoulême de personnes non
vous le savez comme moi que tu veux
alors je t'explique
alors laisse moi t'expliquer j'ai été
victime de menaces de cambriolages de
plusieurs soucis dont tu n'as pas
connaissance d'accord mais ses propos
des cachets la maison qui vont